[Music]
we see these military aircraft deployed
to natural disasters but this time it's
us in crisis and the cargo in this
Hercules from Turkey is personal
protective equipment for our NHS the
government says 742 million pieces of
PPE have been delivered to the Health
Service during the outbreak but it has
to be used sparingly there's enough PPE
to go round but only if it's used in
line with our guidance we need everyone
to treat PPE like the precious resource
that it is that means only using it when
there's a clinical need and not using
more than is needed he said for example
some items didn't need changing between
treating individual patients but health
professionals aren't happy with PPE
being categorized as a precious resource
and the idea that it is potentially been
misused by hospital staff the shortages
that they are facing that they're
telling us about they're not caused by
them misusing kit their cause because
they're still waiting for the kit that
they need their figures on deliveries
are impressive but whether we're
confident or not in what's been said
today we just need to see arrive we will
believe it when we see it
Matt Hancock urged companies to step up
to the plate to manufacture more
supplies last week we featured students
making protective visors on 3d printers
in their old school classroom and an
indication of the shortage is that
they've now had orders of two thousand
units from NHS hospitals across the
country England chief nurse acknowledged
concern it's a challenge it's a struggle
right now to making sure we've got it
everywhere we need it at the right time
these nurses posted pictures of
themselves last month resorting to using
bin bags for protection
it's reported that all three of them
have recently tested positive for kovat
19 and on Wednesday 52 year old
consultant urologist Abdul Chaudhary
died he'd also posted a warning about
the lack of PPE there are doctors who
are now caring for their own colleagues
in intensive care units that that's a
harrowing thought
and you know proper protection can
prevent you becoming infected our Prime
Minister is said to be recovering at San
Thomas's but each day brings another
incomprehensible death toll 980 today
the highest number to date and too often
those trying to stem the rising numbers
of dead are among them
Jason Ferrell Sky News